six-time Pro Bowler 3-time first-team
all-pro safety that is now with the
Baltimore Ravens organization great to
chat with Earl Thomas how you doing Earl
how you doing Rick I'm good yeah life's
good for you
Oh life great where I can't complain at
all so you're you're in Texas right now
in the state of Texas right now chat
with me okay and then you're getting
ready to go in to Baltimore for the
offseason workout program next Monday
correct yes so I'll flower on the 14th
and be for the first day okay what's it
gonna be like for you to walk into a new
spot new facility new digs news
situation new everything
Earl I think I got the first-time
jitters out the way when we had the
press conference I got to see the castle
I got to see some of the staff I
introduced myself to everybody and with
my teammates
I've been talking to to these guys
through group chat so I'm kidding myself
very familiar with everybody around the
building okay and what was it like for
you to be able to be a free agent for
the first time and see what the market
bears it's been a long time coming for
you it seems as you've been you've been
aiming for that day what was that days
or those days like for you Earl create
was very weird they really know where I
would end up was trying to see what my
value was out there and I really thought
I was going to go to Kansas City I had
committed there on a one-year deal worth
like 12 million and like the next
morning I woke up my agents called me
and told I had a better offer with the
Ravens so I definitely took that off of
real quick so interesting you you it
looked like you were gonna wear read and
play in the AFC West and suddenly the
Ravens just swooped in did you have any
meetings with the Ravens at all well I
didn't have any meetings with the Ravens
and I actually had got off the phone
with Andy Reed the night before I found
out the news about the Ravens so you
know and the Chiefs actually about to
mix in their private jet and you know
family was packing up being ready to go
get on a jet go to Kansas City and
the next morning in my agents I told me
that Baltimore really wanted me and they
offered me later dear and I took that
now obviously in terms of contractual
dollars you had fifty five million
reasons to make an awkward phone call to
the Kansas City Chiefs but did did did
you do that personally or did somebody
communicate to them sorry we appreciated
that but we're going to Baltimore yes so
that was the first thing that came to
mind just I didn't want to disrespect
that organization because they obviously
they believed in me for their in one
year and they were committed to me but
my agent told me that they would take
care of it and I just kind of let them
guys work it out and I got work back the
Kansas City understood my situation and
they were fine with it Earl Thomas here
on the Rich Eisen show how close did did
the Cowboys or the Cowboys ever in on
the Mexica sob viously we all know your
your affinity for the state of Texas
did they ever well they're they made
their statements pretty clear in the
media there was really to pay me like I
thought I was worth so obviously I would
have loved to play for the organization
I grew up a big fan of their
organization and all the great players
that came from the organization but it
just didn't work out they're all Thomas
here on the Rich Eisen show so what does
it mean to be paid like this to you Earl
it was great it feels like all the work
that I've put in over the course of my
career wasn't in vain and it feels great
to be appreciated most importantly and
I'm gonna give that same value that they
believed in me I'm gonna try my best to
you know bring my best my best selves to
the game and to the organization now
obviously the last time we saw you you
were being carted off or out before your
press conference with a broken bone in
your left leg how are you feeling how is
your body going into this right now my
body's my body is feeling great I'm
being consistent and you know that's
kind of motor fuel in my face I can't
complain at all where I'm at right now
I'm working hard with my little brother
I got the right people around me in my
corner I think I'm making all the right
decisions with my diet and I have a
shelf that came in so I feel I feel
pretty good well I mean
right now what's your diet or maybe I
need this maybe no I don't want to say
diet I want to say I feel like my bills
are very proportional okay
I'm not overeating you know when I was
living in a country in North Texas lose
their barbecue barbecue family reunions
for no reason everybody comes to the
house you know and I'll just overeat and
no drink a lot and I just kind of cut
cut that out okay so you just now you're
just focused you're lean mean ready to
come down hill and the AFC North
fighting machine is essentially what
you're saying right so I got it I got a
express to you something that so many of
my friends who have been rooting for you
for a decade it breaks their Seahawk
hearts that you are not there anymore
Earl and I'm wondering what your
feelings towards your former
organization are right now as you're
getting set to embark on a new journey
yeah my feelings towards the
organization at the time I was very
heated very frustrated but when you look
at the blessing that the rate that the
ravers organization has believed in me
in gaming is mega deal you know per
dollar stuff behind me and focus
immediately on my new teammates and the
ravers organization but obviously you
know everything that we've been through
everything that I've seen I feel kind of
disrespected but I know it's a business
I know they got other guys they need to
play like you know Frank Lloyd no Bobby
and you know they're very deserving as
well I mean Bobby Wagner is one of the
greatest players that nobody talks about
in the league and I'm wondering do you
look back and think that there was a
Super Bowl or two left on the table in
that town room well obviously the the
game that we lost to Tom and Patriots
that was was riding our grid grips but I
realized and I played with some great
guys and pop it was definitely one of
them I really didn't realize how great
he was playing with him because we were
scrambling trying to you know be the
best we can be and you know you just
stop you don't sit back and you know
understand like man this guy's the best
metal on back in the lead so now that
I've kind of stepped away from the team
and you know hats out of respect on it
I'm very grateful you know
for the time that we had yeah I know I
mean that you talked about one of the
greatest defenses of all time you know
your defense certainly for a few years
there would be up with it it's just a
couple more questions on your your
former team before we turn the page to
the here and the now one more time that
lost in the Superbowl so much has been
made by some of your former teammates at
the team never got over it
is that a fair assessment in your mind
girl you need everybody on the same page
and we never really got back on the same
page but we still play some great
football but we just in play child s
abilities because I feel like we used to
connect it the right way when you're
trying to win championships you need
everybody on the same page and we just
think we just think it there okay and
and last one for you do you ever
envision a time potentially
where you sign a one day or maybe with
Seattle and retire a Seahawk Earl I know
again there's so much football left you
haven't even played it down for the
Ravens yet is that something you'd even
think about envision myself returned as
you know I would never burn the bridge
there you know I still love my teammates
I definitely see myself starting maybe a
one day deal and hopefully they'll bill
hey my my jersey interactors okay Earl
Thomas here on the Rich Eisen show what
do you make of the news recently that
pass interference offensive and
defensive is now a review or a
reviewable penalty in the NFL do you
like that idea Earl I think it's a great
idea especially in the playoffs because
when you look at that game the Saints
and the Rams there was a blown call but
as a defensive player I appreciate cars
like that but as offensive players they
don't appreciate stuff like that so they
definitely did a review so you're not
concerned in any way that in the last
two minutes of a game anything can be
called pass interference or looked at
because that's one of the biggest I just
wanted to be called fair that's it right
is right wrong is wrong I want I want
officiating to be called fair if it's
affiliates opportunity but it is not met
you got to take it away okay
and I know sure Richard Sherman is like
he's been pound at the table or I don't
know how well you've been paying
attention to Twitter and what or how
often you speak to Richard he wants he
wants the product okay but he's been
pounding table that he wants the same
intensity on offensive pass interference
then defensive yeah we want it we want
it to be even plans to everybody knows
this all possibly and what sermons
basically saying we wanted to be called
even like no everybody want to see
touchdowns everybody want to see
somebody getting miles so we want the
same you know we just want a fair shot
that's it okay well look I'm glad how's
your family how's your family doing the
kids the fam good everybody's good ma'am
we just moved in we got started I'll do
house yeah we're happy how many kids do
you have I have three okay what are
their ranges so I have a one-year-old I
have a two-year-old and a six-year-old
Wow so there's lots of challenge flags
being thrown in the and the Thomas
household that's six two and one
okay and you're ready you know what let
me make the Quraish I'm sorry I got a
four month year old I don't want you
okay month your old boy you just round
it up that's okay yeah you are in it
this is huge now you're heading off to
Baltimore for a whole new setting it's a
whole new world for you Earl I'm so
pleased for you that you got paid that
you got what you wanted and and you know
go go crush it everyone's everyone's
talking about the Browns in that
division but I'm sure you're aware about
that so far nice what's even cooler
you know nice quarterback but where we
got the best second in the league man
okay do you want to expound on a little
bit you got the best secondary already
in our secondary we lost a couple of
teachers in the middle with all Suggs
but I think the guys that we have now we
have a chance okay Odell coming over the
middle that's that's all that's all fine
and good Jarvis is you know you got to
have your head on a swivel here comes
Baker Mayfield none of that you're about
to join that fray you know also like the
way we're gonna study
what are we gonna understand opposition
on the field it's gonna be very hard
that you have to get okay
alright oh thanks for the time really
appreciate it let's chat down the line
okay will do you got it that's Errol
Thomas Ravens safety for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app